all right so we're looking at Thomas and
we're looking at these two particular
questions or rather sets of questions
because the each question has a little
bunch of articles and they're about
truth and they're about falsity and you
notice that Thomas quotes a lot of
different people
Augustine view rather a little bit and
so we read on truth and Aristotle a few
things that Aristotle said you might
recognize in there and then a lot of
other people who you don't necessarily
have to worry about when you're trying
to work your way through this but you
might find interesting
yeah we're gonna look at the first
article in question 16 in its entirety
so you get a sense about how to process
these kind of things and then we'll jump
around you know through these different
articles and look at some of his his
doctrines so Thomas is introducing two
terms right off the bat whether truth
exists in the intellect so we saw that
with with Augustine truth was something
that was like outside of your mind and
your mind and formed the truth right
remember that the like I've seen on the
free choice of the will and we saw that
the Anselm there's all kinds of truth
and some of the truth is in your mind
and some of the truth is in your
statements some of its and here we'll
some of its are the very being of things
God Himself is truth it gets really
complicated doesn't it
Thomas is interested in well where is
truth most where is its primary locus so
he's asking whether truth resides only
in the look in the intellect and you
notice he looks at objections the
objections are people saying no it's not
just in the intellect and the first one
that he talks about is Augustine so he
says it seems the truth does not reside
only in the intellect but rather in
things so the truth is like out there in
the world
and our minds then grasp the truth
that's on the world and that's what
makes our minds true that's all it's
kind of like waters
- doesn't and you quote so I've seen he
says Augustine says that is true which
is seen this doesn't work it would
follow that stones hidden in the bosom
of the earth would not be true Stella's
something about this for a minute
when you don't know about something
that's going on and let's say nobody
else knows about it
not even the person who did it let's say
the person who did something forgets
about it is it still true we evaluate
fill this cup up with kerosene and I
leave it here and I put it on the
cupboard and I don't nobody ever like
looks down there because you know you
probably store anything in life no ages
past all right Maris becomes this old
abandoned place and there's still a cup
of kerosene in there I know who cares
what this is it's a bottle right is it
true that there's it's still there yes
right you would stand up so obviously it
says stones hidden in the bosom of the
earth they're true stones so you know
they even though we don't see them he
said he also condemns the following that
is true which is as it appears to the
knower who is willing and able to know
because this from this it would follow
him nothing would be true unless
somebody could know it so he defines
truth Augustine defines truth that is
true which is so it seems that truth is
not so much in our minds it's in the
things out there it's in the the things
themselves and the way that they're put
together just seemed plausible so hold
on to that let's look at the next
objection it says further whatever is
true is true by reason of truth okay
that make sense
if true that truth is if that truth is
only in the intellect nothing will be
true except insofar as it is under
so that because what does your intellect
do was its activity to understand things
right but this is the error of the
ancient philosophers because so that
whatever seems to be true is so so
mutual contradictory seem to be true as
seen by different persons at the same
time so let's think about moral issues
do we always agree about those a lot of
disagreement right that's why you avoid
them at the dinner table sometimes you
want to have a quiet peaceful dinner so
you don't bring up say capital
punishment or abortion or politics or
things like that
well if truth is only in the intellect
then that means it's kind of up for
grabs somebody who might say right truth
is only in your intellect and you
disagree with me then you've got a
different truth than I that I have
don't you so when you believe is true
what I believe is true but that can't be
over all true can it
that doesn't make sense so it must not
be just in a box let's look at the third
one now it says that on account of which
a thing is so is itself more so this is
a little complicated here this is a
metaphysical principle that on account
of which I think so what makes a thing
be what it is the cause of the thing
must be more that way than something
else I'll use a really easy example that
Thomas would probably like think about
fire and heating right what are we
aspired to do think about your stove if
you have a gas stove cook things and how
does the fire do you think what's up
pretty much pretty odd yes you know what
if we had little tick degrees I'm not
sure what propane burns at but I think
paper burns that like 451 we know
okay under your very eyes I think you
could probably get out before but well
you can you can get the stuff in your
pan to get pretty hot - right it's not
as hot with the fire itself and then the
heat in the pan has been communicated
from the fire where is it Klaus and you
know there's some problems of this
analogy I know but just go with me on
this so the fire itself is the cause of
the heat in a body's heat it gives off
heat and the fire is more so that it's
more hot than the state well of the pin
which is communicating keep to the stake
or the stir-fry or mac and cheese or
whatever it is that you're cooking all
right no what are you guys like that
it's a cook in your pants mac and cheese
used to be the staple and a ramen I
suppose yeah what do you guys see steak
okay good life so you get the idea they
have on account of which a thing as so
is itself more so as is evident from the
philosopher he means Aristotle but it is
from the fact that the thing is or is
not so something out in the world that
our thought or our word is true or false
so truth again is out there in the world
it's out there the things not in the
intellect so these are some pretty good
arguments and pretty robust arguments
against truth being in the intellect
right thing then he says on the country
the philosopher says of ourselves does
the true and false reside not in things
but in the intellect now notice what is
he doing there I'll read it to you one
more time
on the contrary the philosopher says the
true of the false resigned out of things
but in the intellect
situation okay so it's structured of
structurally that's what he's doing what
is he doing just in this that used one
of their own army needs like against
them like they quoted everyone he just
quarterback yeah that's the key term you
just quote Sarah stuff says well aerosol
says blah blah blah blah blah right and
does that necessarily mean that it's
right the aerosol can be wrong about a
lot of things I know a lot of people
like to quote people all the time and
lots of times they're dead wrong simply
saying well Plato said that doesn't
necessarily good arguments that have
been made so far what it shows you those
there's yeah there's a possibility of
looking at in a different way so now
we're kind of opening up the field so
let's look at now they might answer that
this is where Thomas is actually telling
you here's what I think about this since
as the good denotes that towards which
the epithet tends so the true denotes
that worked which the intellect ends
daddy's already made it more complicated
as me so what are you reading this for
the first time you're probably like okay
fine if I get what these three arguments
are about how when this how is this some
sort of response to these three
arguments they weren't talking about the
good at all so why are you talking about
that are you just rambling Thomas well
no there's there's a there's
appointments so so yeah that's the good
denotes that towards which the appetite
tense so the true denotes that towards
which the country like time what is that
that's a a analogy isn't it yeah this is
related in this way these things are
related in
in this way so let's actually put this
on the board and think this through so
we've got appetite and that tends
towards is we have a good slice and they
have two notes that's attractive to the
shirt and when you see appetite think
right do that you doesn't just mean your
appetite like your hunger he means your
desire for anything so if you have an
appetite for wealth you know that's a
desire for wealth if you have an
appetite for security appetite for sleep
appetite for all sorts of things
that's desire for those things so desire
tends towards the good right that's what
determines desire do you desire bad
things that you actually know are bad no
you desire bad things sometimes but you
think that they're good when your desire
or you think something about them is
good and that's what you desire likewise
the intellect is the reason why you
habits is to be directed to truth that's
what that's why you know you have a
brain the kind of brain that you do
we're able to grasp things as being true
you know think about being here at
Marist again are you in your classes to
learn and true things or false things
hopefully true things right and if your
instructor teaches you false things how
do you feel
screwed angry yeah I mean you should
feel angry because the whole point of
education is to orient intellects to
what is true so if somebody's giving it
a bunch of false stuff
this is not what education is supposed
to be about you're depriving my
intellect of the truth
try saying that in some classes
professor se says now there's a
difference between the appetite and the
intellect or any knowledge whatsoever
knowledge is according as the thing down
is in the know
so the influence is about the true and
this is about the thing this is about
the number you're the one who actually
knows things and when you know something
Thomas things you have kind of something
like a copy the thing that you're
knowing in your mind and we don't have
to try to spell this out into great
detail there's there's you know this
gets very complicated very quickly what
do you mean by a copy like a
photographic copy you know how does that
work for things like freedom for
democracy or things like that Thomas
thinks that you grasp the essence the
thing with your intellect and sometimes
you know you get it right sometimes you
don't but when you get it right then you
actually have kind of like a copy of it
in your your mind what about a appetites
does the person who's desiring something
already has the thing that they desire
no we desire things because we don't
have them don't we
so I'm going to drink of water once I'm
actually drinking the water I probably
don't want to drink the water in right
my thirst has been satisfied so there's
a dissimilarity here the copy who's a
sort of a copy that's possessed here and
he says so the term of the appetite
namely good is in the object it's over
here on this side for appetite whereas
the term of the intellect is in the
intellect itself so that's over here so
there's there's kind of a system
molarity so he says the appetite itself
is called good at the objects good all
right are there you have any bad desires
any desires
recognises you know being for things
that are not particularly good for you
not sure you do right yeah place protein
count we knows oh yeah yeah if you're a
smoker like that it's hard to not be
reminded that because everybody around
you wants to tell you that you should
you should
okay yours you know you have a desire to
smoke and you take a pop and it feels
good and you're like man I should right
is that a good or bad appetite you'd say
it's a bad appetite because the object
itself is bad right if you have a desire
to here's a common situation here your
best friend he has a very attractive you
know boyfriend girlfriend they seem to
be interested in you you're placed alone
together you know over a weekend they
actually come out and suggest hey you
know did you ever think about if we got
together and you know you think yourself
I shouldn't do this
alright so you a designer too we call
that desire dad because the thing it's
all would be dead right sleeping with
your best friend this is
boyfriend/girlfriend we generally see
those a bad thing right now what about
the intellect you says the Truman the
intellect is so far as it has conformed
to the object understood the aspect of
the true passes from the intellect to
the object understood so the intellect
the truth and the intellect makes the
thing itself true he says the thing may
be understood in relation to an
intellect either essentially or
accidentally I'm going to actually skip
through that fairly quickly because you
know we don't have that much time but
where do you think truth ultimately
would reside then so it's in intellects
now you have an intellect right do you
ever get things wrong though do you have
to discover
along the way so that's why it seems to
you that the true is in the things and
then your intellect is sort of like maps
on to it your intellect is true insofar
as it maps out of things well that's
because there's another intellect Thomas
would say that's actually understanding
all of us and making it the way it is
and what we'd call the truth of things
this is really understanding the whole
schema God understands everything God
has the truth of everything in his mind
because he made everything so there's a
theological kind of framework right yeah
and because of that suppose things have
their their natures they have their
essences they have their the way they
are and we're able to grasp we really
grasp what learned is that makes them
what they are their being and therefore
we have truth in our life and you can
tell that our truth is more true when it
actually Maps on what's called the super
truth right the super truth that's in
the divine light truth with no mixture
of falsity whatsoever no Jenny do you
know what God's mind is like my fam I
don't
but we can know a little bit about it
because it created all these different
things and so when we're getting things
right then our mind is closer to the way
that God sees things yeah you know we
could we could ask ourselves I suppose
at certain points am I seeing things in
any way similar to how God might see in
if the answer is no then we're probably
wrong according to Thomas now let's look
at these objections there is responses
to the objections he says Augustine is
talking about the truth
things and excludes from the notion of
this truth relation to our intellect for
what is accidental is excluded for
memory definition so now we want to go
back to think about essential and
accidental he says we don't judge of a
thing by what is what is in it
accidentally but what is in it
essentially so everything is understood
to be true absolutely so far it is
related to the intellect from which it
depends which is ultimately the divine
mind not our minds think about it this
way it gives you an analogy a house is
said to be true that expresses the
likeness of the form of the art with the
architects mind right so when you're
building something lesson how many of
you to like had the intention at one
time of drawing or painting or sculpting
we're doing something artistic or maybe
musical and you felt like you have this
in you and you're trying to communicate
it out onto paper or canvas or yeah and
it just didn't come off and you felt
very frustrated as a result like you can
see it in your mind or you could hear
the what it was that you're trying to
make us for our south and it just did
not go right the the image in your mind
and the thing out there the thing is
untrue because it doesn't conform to the
image in your mind now it didn't happen
because of your own lack of skill or my
own lack of skill in these cases was
that happen with God no honey I mean
he's God so presumably people have
something to be a certain way he makes
it that way words are said to be true so
far as they're the signs of the truth in
the intellect to be a very innovative
problem expressing yourself I think so
you know we're get a paper back with
teachers like this is unclear really I
thought I did what I was saying but and
you actually didn't perhaps know what
you were saying you just didn't
communicate it that long your words were
laughing truth because they didn't map
onto what was in your your mind so he
says in the same way natural things are
said to be true insofar as they express
the
likeness of the species that isn't the
divine might a stone is called true
which possesses the nature proper to a
stone so truth resides primarily in the
intellect in God's intellect and in our
intellect secondarily in things
according as they are related to the
intellect
now you objection - he says the ancient
philosophers held that the species of
natural things did not proceed from any
intellect but were produced by chance
they saw as truth implies relation to
intellect their complot they're
compelled to base the truth of things on
their relation to our intellect
so if now think about this if the world
is just completely up to chance if
there's if it's inexplicable the things
in the world are just jumbled together
in any way whatsoever then the only
place that you're going to be able to
have truth is been individual human
beings analyzed right that's the only
thing you're going to be able to rely on
when we get to big heart next you know
next week if you can doubt whether
everything is the way that you're
experiencing it then maybe you only have
truth over here that gets to be kind of
a scary proposition you'll see why when
we get to that so I'm gonna and then he
says in a reply - objection 3 although
the truth of our intellect is caused by
the thing it's not necessary that truth
should be there primarily any more than
that health should be primarily in
medicine rather than in the animal the
virtue of medicine and not itself is the
cause of health in the same way that
being of the thing the thing exists the
thing is the way it is the being of the
thing not its truth is the cause of
truth in the intellect when you are
grasping things truly you are grasping
things the way that they are right that
is the being of the thing the truth of
the thing is something not separate but
different from the being of the thing
comes from you actually being a knower
so in a way if we take out out of the
picture in a way you are what makes
things true your knowing them or you're
thinking about them is what makes them
true things out in the world you know
cops don't have the capacity to make
things true you do kind of a interesting
idea doesn't that to wrap their head
around let's move on a bit I'm actually
going to skip over the article to
whether truth resides only in the in
July composing and dividing when you see
that term composing and dividing this
all I'm going to say is I we don't use
those terms we would say things like
analyzing and synthesizing comparing and
contrasting the sort of things that you
are used to doing in papers right your
mind is constantly doing that with its
environment isn't it you're always
making comparisons you're always
breaking things down you're always
putting things together you know putting
things and frameworks and those are all
things that generate truth and your
intellect Thomas we say those are always
as it's your understanding the world you
may not realize this because you're so
good at that you can do it without even
necessarily thinking about it if you
have to think about it all the time
you'd never get anywhere you'd never get
out of here your dorm room
let's move ahead to article four he says
whether good is logically prior to the
truce so now once again we're ten my
goodness and and true
what does he mean by logically prior
what do what do you think that means
that's kind of a hard thing to to wrap
your head around to one thing is there's
something is prior to another thing in
time what does that mean okay yeah so
you're saying that that would be what it
is for goodness to be logically prior to
truth yeah a prior means before right if
you get arrested they look at your prior
record and you might not be probable so
you don't have any which is good
logically prior means that not in time
but in the way that we think about
things it has to come before so how does
our mind when we're looking at the world
and we're taking things in and we're
thinking about them what are we grasping
first how are we experiencing and
understanding things first and this
takes a little bit of you know turning
our attention away from the distractions
of everyday and actually like paying
close attention to how we how we
actually think about things how we
actually do experience this Thomas says
the good and the true are convertible
with being that means that anything that
is good is a being anything that is that
is being is good that's a certain extent
they differ logically it's not the same
thing to have being as to be good or to
be true they're not identical logically
so he says in this manner the true
speaking absolutely is prior to good for
two reasons why well the first reason is
he says the truth
is more closely related to Jesus you
know I didn't put being on here but
here's the thing about things the very
fact that they are things at all means
that they have being and they not only
have being they not only exist they have
the kind of being that they are this is
a piece of chalk right that's it's
beating that's a desk that's a camera
over there's a pen these are all beings
they all have being and they all have
determinant being they have the way in
which they are being we're never we
getting truth from by grasping the
nature of the thing by grasping I said
is a piece of chalk why is that a true
statement because there actually is a
piece of chalk there right if I know I
do this know this is a piece of chalk
true or false
what makes it false yeah very good yeah
you actually sort of like leaped ahead
to first you could have said it well
it's not a piece of chalk at all it's a
pattern right but what does that mean it
doesn't have those those properties it
doesn't have the essential nature of not
necessarily there there could be things
that are imitating the nature of the
dock right but we're able to recognize
them as being duck-like because we grasp
what it means to be to be a duck so you
know what are some examples of duck like
things aren't real ducks robot decoys
you know cartoons about Huey Dewey Louie
Uncle Scrooge I'm Anthony to all people
like to do the duck
that when they take a photo of
themselves Facebook they actually
somebody doing a video where they looks
like a duck quacks like a duck quacks
like a duck okay so they look like a
duck because they've dumped up thing
right and they're walking like a duck
yeah and they're they're also saying
quack quack at the same time okay
they're not duck obviously right and
even you recognize that they're not a
duck he talks about things like that a
little bit further if you know what is
it when we're thinking about movies for
example he doesn't talk about movies but
what is it that we're talking about
artistic representations in a certain
sense they're false right but in a
certain sense they're true because the
things that are being depicted we're
able to grasp those based on what what
they're supposed to be but I don't think
that will we'll get to that necessarily
so back to goodness in the truth so the
truth is based on what things actually
are there being goodness
he says true is more closely related to
being than as good for the true regards
being itself simply and immediately know
just what things are it doesn't make any
sort of value judgments about the things
you might say he was very modern
language where is it good when you when
you grasp something as good you're
making a value judgment aren't you and
that's not saying that you're not
actually getting the thing as it is but
you're at a certain kind of distance
from it compared to its truth so let's
consider this this is a good example
this is not something that you would
automatically consider a good thing is
it it's pretty much a neutral thing when
would this be a good for you
very good yeah or if you want to write a
nasty message on the sidewalk to
somebody you know or if you want to chop
somebody's tighter because your your
give them two hours to park and then
you're gonna give them a ticket but it's
only within certain context that this
would become good for us now let's think
about things that we we do tend to see
as good stress food for example right
you go into the cafeteria you walk in
you're there for a purpose it may be you
know you wants to your friends and
socialize and kill some time
what are you really there yeah which
means get yourself some food because you
can't just like walk in or just get a
plate and so you go and you pick
something out and you look at and let's
say it's what be a dish that could be
kind of if you came off you go to the
pasta burger right and you're having a
pasta thing for you and they usually
have no afraid over there right what
color should upgrade yeah now alfredo
was British would that be a glitter yeah
yeah
is that any wonder what's in it now you
graced the being of the thing this is a
matter of acceptance right you're
looking at it let's say it also smells
like it smells like chemicals right and
not the way it should smell
Alfredo should smell cantebury the
Parmesan cheese and some of that so you
rasp this with your senses you grasp the
being of the thing and you tell yourself
that's not really alfredo sauce I don't
know what you've made there but it's not
an alfredo sauce that you get right away
Tomas would say you perceive it as it
good and then you're able to sort of
pull yourself back from and say no this
would be bad for me to eat even though
I'm hungry because your your attachment
or your apprehension of the goodness of
things it's not quite as immediate as
your grasp of the the truth of things is
Tomas would say the other thing that he
says because knowledge naturally
precedes the appetite you can't desire
things unless you in a certain sense
another right so think about the things
that you've desired in your lifetime
what was your biggest desire your okay
yeah candy allows Y so you probably buy
candy and then something happened when
you were you know like in between nine
and fourteen and what was that girls
yeah not everybody just discovered girls
the one happened to the girls all right
when you were when you were girls not
necessarily I have a lot of people to
keep that stuff forever we go through
adolescence begins right we go through
puberty and what happens
we become aware of new desires we we
look so we start looking when you say
you discover girls right and that's a
good way to put it
because before maybe you didn't want to
play with girls if you're a boy because
you know we kind of separate things oh I
don't know how was it yours everyone
everyone's got different experiences but
you don't grasp looking at the you know
the people that you're attracted to you
don't you don't grasp that until you
start seeing them as potential mates and
something is going on in your body and
that's what's making you now see things
differently but once that happens you
grasp their being differently and then
you can start having desire for that
and at first it's very confusing right
that's why they have all the books for
you and health class and stuff like that
changes you may have new feelings
they're talking about desire and now
you've been you know living with that
for a while and I'm willing to bet that
that's quite a few of you when you were
in middle school high school you may
have been into your studies but a lot of
a lot of it was probably in part because
you're trying to please people and you
want to know stayed and parents good
graces and you know get out of the get
out of the school and move on to college
and stuff like that is it a little bit
different for you now that you've been
able to choose your own course of study
where you're going to be going
are you finding yourself more interested
in whatever it is that you're studying
you you see that as a good and you you
desire it you want to pursue whatever it
is that that counts as knowledge in that
field you want to absorb that you may
not care about the core classes I can
understand that I'm not advocating that
but there's something that attracts you
doesn't there and could you be attracted
to that if you didn't know about it
first you have to have grass with
something the way it is then you can
begin to desire it so no fashion for
example right imagine that you have
grown up in a world where how would we
go to be eliminate that no fashion
magazines no fashion shows nobody able
to talked about it we all wear that we
all wear this it's the entire time right
brown pants and grey sweaters look at
uniform pretty drab doesn't it would you
be on the same desire for for you know
studying fashion than you do prefer
making things differently it might be
like a reaction is that I just wish
something wasn't great right but that's
kind of in Coweta it's it's it's hard to
put your finger I bet that if you know
we asked you to when I brought you up
here at the board you could tell us
about what things you would like to
actually produce you know you probably
actually have plates
I'm guessing and projects that you've
done to some degree that I understand my
daughter actually is doing that sort of
thing she's into them that's what I'm
hoping miss you and I should go here at
Marist
we have to know something at least to
some degree before we can desire it we
have to know what it is before we can
desire to Thomas would say so in a way
truth is prior to goodness for Thomas
Aquinas I'm gonna skip over the is God
truth then and let's look at article six
now is there only one truth according to
which all things are true this is
something that ants upset in the truth
wasn't it very very close to the end he
said there's one big truth and truth is
sort of like time we tend to think of
things like the time of this time of
this class for example but this class is
within time itself isn't it and so all
truths
according to Ansel are
then truth itself which turns out to be
turns out to be job it's a review so
what is Thomas say this is pretty
typical Thomas he says in one sense
truth whereby all things are true as one
in another sense it's not so he's saying
well yes enough and he actually
considers the end zone here it says in
proof of which we must consider that
when anything is predicated in many
things you nificantly that means
whenever we say some thing like for
instance duck right whenever we say doc
you nificantly you nificant univocal a
sorry
which means meaning the same thing each
time then it's found in each of them
according to its proper nature so let's
use a duck again we use Duncan in what
what Thomas would call equivocal in an
illogical ways so there's a there's a
sports team the Ducks right it's a
hockey team where do they play from yeah
okay so they're not ducks the guys out
there they have you know that I suppose
with duck on new jersey but they're not
actually ducks they they couldn't
because only human being able to write
the ducks in Walt Disney movies if they
existed they would be dogs but really
they may be very strange ducks because
what's something they do that ducks
don't do talk yeah that's pretty a
pretty important as ducks to talk to
each other they talk to each other by
going back quack and then they can hiss
at each other too sometimes
anything that you want to call a doc and
mean the same thing has to be in that
species and we can have all sorts of
other things robot decoys that walk
around but that's not really a duck in
the same sense and it doesn't mean you
can't call it a duck or here's another
example yeah
Howard well he's like a Disney doc right
no Howard that that was the eighties
movie got kicked up into Versalles to
earth same sort of deal he's there's a
fictional character and butyl oxidant
all that it does they'd be the same
thing let's consider a case where we
have a much weaker connection just to
see what the opposite of you Nikolas
with equivocal if you go to Wisconsin
Dells and I think they also have
something a lot like this in Jersey
somewhere you can ride on these vehicles
that are called docks maybe know what
these are
yeah World War two amphibious military
vehicles they were used for landing
troops and material like at d-day and
now that you know they've adapted into
civilian use and they've got wheels on
them and they have like a propeller so
they can go on either either land or sea
I think that weird transmission that
allows them to shift back and forth to
them and they're still running even
though it's like you know after more
than half a century later now why are
they called thoughts because they're
kind of like docks in a certain way
what's the one way in which they're like
ducks ducks can walk around on land and
dusty go on water that's a pretty loose
similarity isn't it you could call them
geese if you wanted to you could there
are other animals are we to think of
that our Birds that going in and out of
the water crocodiles you know there's
actually a bit more like crocodiles them
that they're warm go ahead and talk but
we don't call crocodile to come dogs
that's just sort of random that we
picked that term yeah there's also the
acronym that described a tougher oh okay
and acronyms would be although they
probably were attracted to the acronym
in parks like you think it Duck acronym
is like a you know
letters that stand for thanks so he says
when anything is predicated of many
things analogically what we mean by that
well like Howard the Duck would be an
illogical because he looks a lot like a
duck he's got the same shade presumably
has duck like desires I guess
I had spent a lot of tennis as I've seen
that Uncle Scrooge is less dock like in
a way in that he is so attracted to gold
and ordinary ducks are very attracted to
gold are they
maybe shiny things I don't know but
anything is predicated of many things
and logically it is founded only one of
them according to its proper nature and
from this the rest are denominated so
what does it mean this all fancy
language when we have this analogical
relation first you have to know you have
to understand the truth of the actual
thing the dock of the species and then
you can start comparing all sorts of
other things to it so to use the example
of healthiness healthiness is predicated
of an animal that's healthy urine
because of the back then there was a big
thing for their medical knowledge you
still do it someone today and a medicine
not that health is only in the animal
but health is primarily in the end or
you know you when we talked about health
we primarily mean what's in you the
medicine by itself doesn't do any good
if your death all right the medicine can
be as healthy as you like or a diet can
be as healthy as you like
but if all the human beings are dead we
don't care the whole point of them is to
make human beings healthy right that's
where the primary meaning resides and we
can talk about medicine as being healthy
because what it produces health or it
you know prevents us from losing or a
diet we can talk about it's healthy
because it produces health we can see a
diet is unhealthy cause of damages
health think about all the different
tests that you'd have to take when you
go to the doctor more often they take
your blood than then your I guess back
in medieval times those looks taking me
here is more often but you know you go
into what else will they do they they
look
and you know they get the scope and look
in your ears and your eyes those are all
signs of health right they listen to
your heart heartbeat sounds good
your heart is healthy at least as far as
so that's analogically connected so he
says although health is neither in
medicine nor urine getting in either
there is something whereby the one
clauses and the other indicates huh
now we have said that truth resides
primarily in the intellect and
secondarily in things accordingly as
they are related to the divine in July
if therefore we speak of truth as it
exists in the intellect according to its
proper danger remember the question here
is is there one single truth or are
there multiple truths if we're talking
about it as a primary sense each one of
you as an intellect writer there's truth
in your intellect there's truth in your
intellect there's truth in your
intellect do you have what's in his own
intellect know you've got your own minor
right we're not all one big hive brain
kind of thing thank god you're not
reading my mind right now I know all
right I'm not reading ears I can tell
you that because I can barely keep track
of my own thoughts you know so if we're
talking about it in the accents in the
primary sense no truth is that this is
multiple at this it's all over the voice
but if we're talking about it as it is
in things that all things are true by
one primary truth and what's that
primary truth well this truth over here
the truth that's in the mind of God who
grasps understands all the things rests
the entire universe as it is and also
you know presumably aren't we also
things in the universe you and me so
it's not like God's mind would be cut
off from from our minds our minds would
also be
some things that God would would know
that's why you know he's even some
people are comparing them it's a Santa
Claus in that you know Santa Claus sees
you when you're sleeping
those are near awake those wouldn't have
been bad or good right God even knows
more than that you know what you're
thinking while you're thinking because
he knows everything so if we're talking
about truth of math sense which not
Thomas dopes it's not the primary sense
then truth is one because they're in
compasses can I didn't even know about
our our truth and our falsity in our
yeah so there's two Papa there's two
answers to that if what you're asking is
what if this is actually correct and an
individual person doesn't believe in God
then God knows that that person doesn't
believe in God and it doesn't make any
difference if the person doesn't believe
in God you know no it wasn't the same if
you take that out of the picture is that
what you're asking
that's a deeper question if you have the
kennedy point that thomas does and you
take that out of the picture i was
thinking about this on the way here then
we would be left with just things over
here right and there would be no one
truth that makes all the things over
here and being true and we might not
even be able to be sure about this stuff
is some perspective what's that wouldn't
it be less perspective
yes very good once you take out out of
the the two mystic picture it all
becomes a matter of individual or we
could have like you'd all be on the same
page because I'm the boss and I make us
all think the same thing because if we
don't
social disorder but it doesn't only be
locally true right if you take god this
happens for a lot of different
philosophical friends if you take God
out of the picture of this where he
doesn't seem to be doing awful you take
him out of the picture were all left in
our own sort of individual bubbles so
and that's a very deep problem compared
to the question of well I just don't
believe you exist and but he he believes
that I exist and she knows that exist
right yeah yeah here's the thing if you
take God out of the picture and you just
don't want to get something like what
he's affording here you better find
something else to put in there so
Plato's forms that could do that kind of
thing
or maybe you come up with well science
will take the place of this or you know
just nature by itself
does this term God into nature the way
somebody like Spinoza we're not going to
read Hegel to a certain extent to
because that that's that's a way to try
to get around that and you know this is
just a historical model do you know why
people haven't did that because this
idea of God that we had more or less
well established in the Middle Ages by
the middle of the modern period people
are saying yeah I don't believe in this
anymore and it became widespread in
society so that's somebody like me Chia
at the end you could say God is dead not
meaning that there was a natural God who
lived and then died but that the idea of
God that was providing us the ground for
the truth of beings which we were taking
in had disappeared had we lost faith in
it and once that happened that it's all
up for grabs
according to somebody like Nietzsche so
you know that's actually a good place to
end and thank good questions